le centre pompidou à paris fermé pour
cause de rajeunissement contrairement à
certaines rumeurs et certaines
informations qui couraient ces derniers
temps sur la vétusté voir le le
délabrement de l'édifice le centre
pompidou se porte bien mais il est
victime de son succès alain doublé ce
qui est daniel levy nous offre une
petite visite que je qualifierais de
techniques 27 mille visiteurs par jour
au lieu des sept mille prévus à
l'origine
certains jours le centre pompidou reçoit
jusqu'à 40000 visiteurs qui se partage
entre la visite du musée d'art moderne
le centre de création industrielle
l'institut de recherche musicale et
surtout la bibliothèque 1700 places
assises toujours prises d'assaut face à
une telle sollicitation il y à usure
rapide et passages réservés au public
moquette rampe d'accès aux heures
d'ouverture des milliers de personnes
passent ici
les expertises ont démontré que la
structure du bâtiment était en bon état
bien sûr la mauvaise qualité d'une
peinture recouvrant une poutrelle du
cinquième étage fait mauvais effet ainsi
que celle ci d'ailleurs mais la sécurité
des visiteurs n'est pas remise en cause
moi de dire absurde sur la sécurité nous
ne sommes pas un endroit où nous sommes
un endroit où on a besoin de travaux et
bien évidemment des problèmes il ya des
problèmes de maintenance comme dans tout
bâtiment mais ça s'est levé à bas la
gestion quotidienne d'un bâtiment qui ne
pose aucun problème de sécurité
aucun problème en revanche qui doit être
complètement revu c'est l'accueil et la
présentation des expositions consul ya
20 ans le musée a pris un coup de vieux
comparé au louvre par exemple le coût du
chantier est évalué à 400 millions de
francs
faudra-t-il fermer le centre pompidou
pendant les travaux pendant combien de
temps
réponse dans quelques jours